I don't want to spend a ton of time on
this but I have an example for you of
what happens when you confront one of
these right-wing Republicans who repeats
fake stories one such fake story is
schools are putting litter boxes in the
bathrooms so that students who identify
as animals can use the litter box as
their bathroom
it's made up
didn't happen it has been repeated and
repeated and repeated but it did not
happen Don balduck who's running in New
Hampshire was confronted about it why
did you say that that's just not true
and he says well it's what I was told
you made it a recent event about
children using litter boxes in schools
you know there's there's no that's not
what I said okay well then tell me what
you said I heard the audio so what yeah
so uh what I was talking about is all
the craziness going on in our schools
and this is just one of them and I had a
I had a parent and a student in that
audience who came up to me
told me all about it yeah guys listen a
parent and a student if it was only a
parent okay if it was only a student but
a parent and a student told them
students who identify as animals are
going pee pee and poo poo in a litter
box so he started repeating it I've had
that all across the state so I'm only
articulating what I heard from you
skaters parents he didn't make it up he
heard it guys children
craziness is going on in our schools
Senator Hassan is responsible for it
she's double down on all the bad
education policies out there understand
how crazy this is it's not happening in
schools and Maggie Hassan has nothing to
do with it because it's not taking place
sir why our children can't read and
write the grade level why we have the
lowest scores why we can't compete in
the world why our children require
remedial courses to go to college
because she has took her eye off the
ball on the future of our nation and
that's our children
you had a parent tell you yes and
student happening in the schools yeah
the school has come out and said that
that's completely false well you know
they they came out and said they didn't
ask children they came out and said they
didn't do a lot of things right they
don't teach CRT which they do they don't
treat transgender which they do they
teach transgender
I'm not backing down okay he's not
backing down from something that is just
not happening and so you can Google this
it's widely documented there's a good
NBC news article from
um a couple weeks ago how an urban myth
about litter boxes in schools became a
republican talking point at least 20
Republicans claimed schools are making
accommodations for students who identify
as cats the school districts say these
claims are untrue we would be able to
write this off as an insanely stupid
timeline
if people weren't falling for it
and if people weren't actually being
influenced in their votes based on these
bogus false stories really scary stuff
make sure you're following us on
Instagram at davidpackman show to see
all of the clips that we played today
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate-controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night